Who here, a year or two ago,
thought that they'd be living
through a global pandemic?
A new virus that spread across the world
and killed millions.
One of the scariest things
about this virus
is that when it broke out
we had next to no cures or treatments
to fight against COVID-19.
But viruses, new and old,
aren't our only worries.
From infectious bacteria
that have become immune to our antibiotics
to increased rates of cancers,
humanity is struggling to find solutions
to our ever-evolving medical needs.
To find our medicines of the future,
we’re turning to Mother Nature for help.
My name is Sam Afoullouss,
and I’m an underwater alchemist.
But instead of turning led to gold,
I'm turning Ireland's hidden treasure,
deep-sea coral reefs,
into our medicines of the future.
For thousands of years,
we have turned to natural remedies
made from the plants and animals
that surround us
to cure us of our ailments.
Put your hand up if,
when you have a cold or a cough,
you use natural treatments like honey
or ginger to help relieve your symptoms.
Hot whiskeys?
(Laughter)
The reason why these natural remedies work
is they rely on molecules
called specialized metabolites
that are mainly produced
by organisms that can’t move,
like plants and mushrooms,
to defend themselves
from diseases and predators.
Over the past 200 years,
scientists have traveled
to the four corners of our world
in search of organisms that may contain
these medicinal molecules.
This fundamental research has resulted
in over half our medicines today
being derived and inspired
by natural sources.
Although these scientists scoured
the surface of our planet
for organisms with these
potential medicines,
there was one area
that remained underexplored --
and it just so happened to be
the biggest part.
The oceans.
Our oceans cover over three quarters
of the Earth's surface
and contain the most biodiverse
ecosystems on our planet.
In Ireland, we own eight times
more ocean than we do land,
and it's filled with forms of life
that seem alien to us.
All of these creatures you see here,
I photographed in Irish waters
along the Connemara coastline,
and you can discover them for yourselves
if you visit rock pools
or snorkel through the kelp forests.
When Jacques Cousteau invented
scuba diving in the 1940s,
this provided scientists with the tools
required to explore
these diverse ecosystems.
Now they could spend hours underwater,
uncovering hundreds of new species
from colorful corals
to spectacular sponges
of all shapes and sizes.
When chemists got their hands
on these samples
and started analyzing the molecules
that these animals made,
they were amazed.
New molecules,
many of which chemists thought
would be impossible to form.
But then Mother Nature
had something to say.
When they tested the potential of turning
these new molecules into medicines,
they found that many
of these new molecules
could kill the most potent
of drug-resistant bacteria,
destroy the most virulent of cancers
and even be used to treat pain.
There are 17 medicines today
in your local pharmacies and hospitals
that are derived from marine sources.
One of these medicines,
in particular, ziconotide,
was isolated from the Conus magus,
also known as the magical cone snail.
What's magic about this sea snail
isn't just its beautiful
shell and pattern,
but one of the natural
molecules it produces
is such an effective painkiller
that it’s 1,000 times
stronger than morphine.
And you’re probably asking yourself:
Why would a sea snail produce something
that’s 1,000 times
stronger than morphine?
Is that why they're slow?
(Laughter)
And the answer?
Ingenious evolution.
See, these sea snails hunt fish,
and they don't have the speed
to chase down their prey
like a lion hunts a gazelle.
So instead, they harpoon their prey
injecting it with a potent
mixture of neurotoxins
like ziconotide, that paralyze
the fish instantly.
It's ziconotide's ability to target
the nervous system of vertebrates like us
that makes it such
an effective painkiller.
And while scuba diving
was a revolutionary leap forward,
allowing scientists to study
our coastal marine ecosystems,
our oceans extend far past
our shores to unimaginable depths.
We can only dive so deep
before the physical pressure
pressing down causes lethal effects.
This left the vast majority
of our oceans underexplored.
More people have been to space
than have been to our oceans'
deepest depths.
To find our medicines of the future,
we went to explore these depths
on the research vessel
The Celtic Explorer,
and sailed south from Irish shores
to some of the largest geographical
features that scar our planet.
Submarine canyon systems
like Whittard Canyon,
where the sea floor drops
from 300 meters to 3,000 meters.
And it's here in some of the most extreme
environmental conditions in the world
that deep-sea coral reefs flourish.
Conditions at these depths are so extreme
we have to use a state of the art
robotic submarine
the size of a minibus
to collect our samples.
And when I say extreme conditions,
I really mean extreme.
Unlike the coral reefs
that the cone snails inhabit,
instead of the water being
warm and tropical,
it's the same temperature as your fridge.
Instead of it being bright,
clear and sunny,
it's pitch black and has never seen
the light of day,
permanently bathed in eternal darkness.
And instead of being able
to swim around freely,
if you were to dive to these depths,
you would be crushed in seconds
with the sheer pressure,
equating to the weight of 20 elephants
standing on your head.
Even with these harsh conditions,
deep-sea coral reefs are among the most
biodiverse ecosystems in the world,
rivaling that of the Great Barrier Reef
and the Amazonian rainforest.
In this one picture alone,
there are hundreds of unique species,
from starfish to sea fans,
cup corals to crinoids,
all of which have adapted
over millions of years
to thrive in this unforgiving environment.
Many of these animals are new to science
and remain in the final frontier
in studying life on our planet.
Some of these animals are so alien,
like deep sea jellyfish,
that they even inspired the creatures
in James Cameron's "Avatar"
after the director explored the deep sea.
This abundance of biodiversity
creates competition,
especially between the filter-feeding
animals to fight for space,
to grow as far out into the water
currents as possible
to catch as much food as possible.
For millions of years,
this battle for space and food
has raged on in the darkness,
resulting in some of the most beautiful
biological creations
our world is yet to see.
And this is an example
of some of that beauty.
A two-meter-wide trumpet sponge
we found at a depth of 1.5 kilometers.
This species of sponge
has evolved to grow
an intricate skeleton
of interwoven glass fibers
that stretch out into the current.
But this beauty comes with a dark side.
It turns out the battle for these sponges
and corals to survive and thrive
is a battle that relies
on chemical warfare.
My aim is to isolate
these chemical weapons,
which we can then utilize
in our own fight
against microbes and cancers.
If you look closely at this sponge,
there are these tiny yellow dots.
Each of those yellow dots is a coral-like
animal growing on the sponge,
using it as a scaffold
to feed in the currents.
This can negatively affect the sponge.
So in a response,
the sponge and its microbiome
produce toxic compounds
to kill the corals.
And in a response to that,
the corals produce their own toxic
compounds to kill the sponge.
It's these compounds we aim to develop
into new anti-cancer therapies
and future antibiotics.
But these reefs
contain thousands of species,
and each species may contain
thousands of molecules,
so you might imagine that finding the one
that could be a cure for a type of cancer
or might stop the next pandemic
would be like the proverbial finding
a needle in a haystack.
In the dark.
(Laughter)
But the same way that we soak berries
and spices in alcohol to make gin,
we soak our corals and sponges in alcohol
to make coral and sponge gin,
which we call extract.
We then feed this extract
to different diseases --
cancers, malaria, viruses,
even brain-eating amoebas --
and we wait.
Most of the time, nothing happens.
But every once in a while,
one of these extracts
manages to kill a disease,
letting us know it contains
a natural molecule
with the potential to be turned
into a medicine.
We then isolate these molecules
and test them against the disease again
until we find the one,
the one molecule that has resulted
from millions of years of evolution
in our oceans' dark depths
that we can now use
in our own wars against cancers,
bacteria and viruses.
But once we find these medicines,
we can't just rip these animals
from the reef as our source.
That would destroy
the very vital biodiversity
and resulting competition that created
these molecules in the first place.
We don't need to come up
with a complex mechanism
for manufacturing them in a lab.
Some of these molecules are so complex
we couldn't even if we tried.
But Mother Nature has done
the hard work for us.
Hidden in the DNA of these animals
and their associated microbes
are the genes which carry
the biological recipes
for producing these molecules.
Using cutting-edge techniques,
we can take these genes and insert
them into microbes like yeast,
allowing us to grow them in a bioreactor,
getting the microbes to do
the hard work for us,
producing our medicines
in a sustainable, cost-effective way
without the need for harsh chemicals,
such as heavy metals,
that can be required in more
traditional manufacturing processes.
Our research isn't just to help
protect the health of humanity,
but also to protect the health
of these hidden reefs.
Deep-sea reefs wrap around
our entire planet,
and already over half the reefs that exist
have been destroyed,
turned to lifeless rubble
by trawling and longline fishing.
With new threats on the horizon,
like deep-sea mining,
they're in more danger now
than ever before.
By proving that their unique biodiversity
can be a natural resource
for providing us with new medicines,
not only does this give a public health
incentive to protect these reefs,
but a financial one also.
Like how safari tours provide
the economic incentive
to conserve savanna ecosystems,
potential profits
from pharmaceutical sales
could provide the financial sustainability
to explore and protect these reefs.
We need new medicines today
more than ever before,
and the incredible biodiversity
that deep-sea reefs offer
have created a fantastic library
of natural molecules,
which we can develop
into our future medicines.
Already, our research group has found
potential medicines against asthma,
malaria and even COVID-19,
showing the unbelievable
potential of these reefs.
To protect our own health
we need to protect the health
of deep-sea coral reefs.
Our future pharmacies
are hidden in our seas.
Thank you.
(Applause)